hi there Steve Kaufman Here I am in our
little yard here we're in Palm Springs
my wife and I and so I want to talk
about travel and language learning three
questions and people have asked me to
come you know present my conclusions at
the front so they don't have to listen
to my ramble
three questions number one is travel a
major motivator for language learning
yes absolutely second question is it
necessary to travel to the country in
order to learn languages
no third question if you travel to the
country where the language is spoken
will that help your language learning
not necessarily so those are the
conclusions now let's get into detail
for me Travel has always been or has
been one of the main motivators in
language when it got to be careful that
Carmen doesn't trip over a flower or
soup acts out here there are other
motivators like I'm motivated to learn
about a country's history having a
friend in the language can be a major
motivator or a relative so there could
be many motivations or motivating
factors however travel is a major
motivator so having a goal like in my
case when I learned Czech I wanted to
study it for a year and then after a
year go to Prague and speak so that was
a major motivator it made it very
concrete I had a specific goal so to
that extent wanting to travel to the
country even if you can't travel this is
the other thing if you're located
somewhere where you have perhaps only a
slight possibility of traveling to a
spanish-speaking country or to China you
still have thought that one day you
might travel there can become a
motivator because motivation is so
important to language learning so travel
can be a major motivator but it needn't
be the only one as I say it can be an
interest in the culture in say anime for
people I'm not interested in anime at
all but some people are I'm interested
in history so travel can be a great
motivator now the second question is do
you need to travel to the country in
order to learn the language there the
answer is no and I'll give you a number
of examples first of all in my own
experience
I learned Mandarin Chinese in Hong Kong
Hong Kong in the 60s was not a Mandarin
speaking environment so I was not
surrounded by Mandarin I didn't hear
Mandarin on the radio I couldn't go out
and talk to shopkeepers or our
passers-by in Mandarin the only people
with whom I spoke Mandarin were my
teachers and a very limited number of
men
commander and speaking friends whom we
met so I might just as well have been in
New York Paris Tokyo so for me I didn't
need to be in a Mandarin speaking
environment and after nine months I
learned a lot of Mandarin but I was
motivated by my interest in the history
and the literature my reading my
listening and all the things that kept
me going at my Mandarin Studies I get
another example even with regard to
check I spent a year listening to check
radio an hour an hour and a half a day
studying it linked with the goal of
going to Prague but in the end I spent
five days in Prague I spent a year
working on my check so the five days in
Prague were an opportunity for me to
sort of convert my somewhat passive
learning into more active learning but
in terms of the amount of time that I
spent I spent a whole year studying
check on my own in Canada five days in
Prague so being in Prague per se was not
the condition for learning so that's the
second question the third question is
does going to the country ensure that
you learn the language and there again
the answer is no most people if they
have an opportunity to travel to you
know Mexico Spain Italy Prague China
probably they're only going to spend a
week or two weeks there they can't learn
the language in one or two weeks even if
they spend two or three months there it
may not be enough it's the amount of
study that you do beforehand that will
determine how well you can take
advantage of your stay even living in
the country doesn't ensure you're gonna
learn the language when I lived in Japan
very few foreigners learned learned
Japanese and for that matter
you know even if you're in the country
where the language is spoken even and
and I went to Japan's but speaking
essentially no Japanese so I was
surrounded by Japanese people but most
of my learning activity was listening
and reading to things of interest to me
I had to build up my capability in the
language before I could actually
interact with people so regardless of
whether you're in the country or not the
strategy has to be and I mentioned this
in my book the strategy has to be to
build up your own language world of
things that are of interest to you
things that you can read and listen to
and build up your vocabulary allow your
brain to become sort of accustomed to
the language start speaking with people
which we can do it and this is another
point today with the internet access to
people via Skype access to tremendous
resources on the Internet you can build
you can create your own language
learning or language world wherever you
are and that's the major sort of
activity and if you are lucky enough to
have the opportunity to travel to the
country where the language you're
learning is spoken so much the better
that can be a major motivator as you
prepare yourself for that opportunity
and eventually if you do go there
obviously the more time you spend there
the more you're interacting with people
the better you're going to get but the
foundation can be built at home and then
when you get the opportunity you can
really take advantage so that's kind of
a summary of this whole issue of travel
and language yes it's great to travel
and I love going to countries where I
can speak the language and it's a major
benefit and bonus and reward for
learning the language but it's not a
condition you can learn the language
very well at home and even if you do go
to the country where the language is
spoken if you haven't had if you haven't
put that effort into preparing yourself
using your own language world you won't
be able to take advantage of it so there
you have it unfortunately we are going
to have to leave sunny as California in
a few days and go back to Canada where
the weather is not as nice thanks for
listening I look forward to your
comments and I want to hear about your
experience
thank you